well you you actually glossed over one
of my favorite parts is because i
sometimes go to those beaches you know
you just go
and you thought it would be fun to
propose on the beach yeah we had been at
a beach so we're from new york you know
i don't know the layout that well in la
i know that malibu is nice from the 80s
so
i was i thought what's nicer than
something that was nice a long time ago
so i
i drove with my uh fiance anna or my
girlfriend at that moment and i went to
this beach uh off the pch next to this
restaurant called gladstones now in
fairness to me we had been at that beach
a couple weeks ago and the sun was
setting and it was beautiful you know
and i thought if i had a ring i'd
propose right now on the day that i took
her the beach was i don't know how to
phrase this crawling with homeless
people
literally cr like one person like in the
beginning of monty python holy grail was
just digging in sand
angrily trying to dig to china and
we started walking
and you know and part of me was like is
this funny
if i propose here
we're walking there's a guy and we get
to a point where i'm like i think in the
next 10 yards we might have some clear
space
we might have a window a window between
maniacs
and then a shirtless man walks to the
edge of the ocean and goes
and anna said there are a lot of other
beaches in malibu and i said that's
right and so we got back in the car and
we drove way further down to another yes
yes oh my god so she was wise she was
very wise i mean she knew i'm using it
like the she knew i was gonna propose
yeah do you remember how she knew
no she knew what was up because i was
like
you know we gotta look it was all it was
a disaster i got on
we started driving and i said we're not
going to the airport you know i thought
we'd spend one more day in la and like i
have never
done any kind of surprise before so
right away it was just dead silence in
the car and she was like okay
and then it takes a while to get from
those feelers to malibu apparently so
we sat in silence in the car
luckily my manager kept calling to say
my pilot hadn't been picked up
no it was worth it it was totally it was
really funny it was so tense and then
when i proposed it was really worth it
so all of it was great